- I'm going to be honest
with you, I don't.
I don't, I don't.
I'm not, I'm not good with...
I'm not good with stress.
I just get the...
I break down and like uh.
- [Interviewer] How much do you think that
your childhood experience
with all the stuff
that happened when you were young
has to do with your lack of-
- My lack-
- [Interview] Your lack of
desire for responsibility?
- It has a lot to do with it.
Oh my God, does it?
Yes, it does.
- [Interviewer] So Keesha,
where are you from originally?
- I am originally from
Monterey, California.
- [Interviewer] Monterey?
- Yeah. I was born in
Carmel, raised in Monterey.
I moved around.
- [Interviewer] How'd
you end up down here?
What got you here?
What happened that got you down here?
Can we start with your childhood?
- A few things.
A few things got me down here
and one of them was drugs
and the other was not
having nowhere to stay.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And I got an ex boyfriend
that stayed down here,
so I came down here.
I was supposed to come down here to visit
and he was going to help me
to do the little program thing
and you know, go to the mission.
I was drug-free for a year.
So, I was clean for a year and I ran into
a cousin through marriage,
which, I'm now divorced
and ended up right back in
the same, same situation.
Yeah. Addiction.
- [Interviewer] So, let's
start with your childhood.
Tell me about your childhood.
- Okay.
Okay, my childhood.
I rarely talk about it, but
let's see, where can I start.
- [Interviewer] I know
it's hard for some people.
- I wanna say my upbringing was,
was good up until my dad
got back from Vietnam.
My dad is in the military.
My mom, she was working
for the civil service,
which is secretary for the military.
When he came back, I
assume, now, now I know now,
around that time it was
the era where there was,
they were doing opiates and
stuff like that, shooting up.
And that's what he was doing.
And in the midst of all
that, he was abusive.
So he would, you know, come
in and beat up on my mom
and then he would come and
harass me and my sister,
he would-
- [Interviewer] Harass you sexually?
- Sexually, yeah, me, not my sister.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- Let's see.
I was probably, I'm not exactly sure,
but I know I was like in
the third or fourth grade.
He would, yeah, he would touch, feel,
he never penetrated, but at
the same time he was grinding
and oh you know, all the other stuff.
And if I didn't do what he, you
know, if I had said anything
or if I didn't agree, he
would threaten to spank me.
- [Interviewer] Was
your mom aware of this?
- No.
My mom was a working momma, she worked in,
she worked every day, she worked hard.
You know, like I said-
- [Interviewer] And you
couldn't say anything?
- I really couldn't, no,
I couldn't say anything,
'cause he was like, the monster.
He was like, he was, he was a monster.
He was, he really was.
I mean, I've witnessed
all kinds of things.
You know, I'd go in a room
and there are tourniquets
and needles and you know.
I walked into the bathroom one time
and there was a dead
man in our, in our tub
with the needle still in his arm,
with the tie still around his arm.
- [Interviewer] You
didn't see that coming.
- I'll never forget, I will never-
I see that, when I talk about that,
it's like it was yesterday.
I mean, because it's so vivid,
it's like it's right there.
And I remember,
I remember my mom going crazy,
you know, going ballistic.
He slaps her, beats
her up and then he goes
and gets a friend and then he
politely take the body and-
My mom liked nice things.
My mom's never, we've never
been on welfare or anything.
So he took the body, wrapped it up in,
what do you call those?
The, like, the carpets,
they're really expensive.
They're like, what are they called?
Forgot what they're
called, but it's a carpet.
And he rolled him up in the carpet
and threw him in the
dumpster like he was, yeah.
- [Interviewer] He threw
the body in the dumpster?
- Yes.
I witnessed all of this.
And then, and after that it was like, he,
he would disappear.
My dad would disappear for days at a time.
You know?
And the last thing that
I remember of my dad
was when he came and he beat my mom so bad
that both her eyes were shut.
She had broken ribs.
She was hospitalized for about a month.
Oh yeah, we thought we was gonna lose her.
It was scary.
It was really, really scary.
He had took all that he could.
Anything he could sell.
He left us with no food.
He would take my mom's car.
He sold the car.
You know, that was the
last time I seen my dad
was when he beat her like that.
But that never, that never stopped my mom.
My mom still, you know,
still stayed strong.
And then after that, I, about
a year or two after that,
I got molested again.
My cousin.
My cousin on my dad's side.
That was like-
- [Interviewer] How old were you then?
- Then I was, I was at least, what, 12.
12, 13.
- [Interviewer] Still young.
- Still young, yeah, still young.
But everything, you know, it's like,
I don't know what it was, but
I know I had to put everything
like this, way back here.
And everything was okay
because my mom made sure
that we had everything we needed.
Everything, anything we needed.
Food and anything that we
needed, she made sure we had it.
And you know, things started
getting a little bit better
and started changing when
she went and got another job.
And that's when she
went to the Academy for the
Department of Corrections.
So, when she started working for the
Department of Corrections,
things changed drastically.
I mean, we moved out.
We were living in the projects.
We moved out of the projects.
I mean, it was like we had
everything that we ever wanted,
me and my sister.
And then she got a new boyfriend.
Then she started doing crack.
Back then it was called, what, freebasing?
So she, when she started freebasing,
it's like everything went right back to
the way it used to be.
It's just that my dad wasn't there.
And it was her get high buddies.
You know,
I almost, I almost came to a point
where I almost killed
one of them and yeah.
And you know, thanks to my
mom I didn't, but you know
I had the pistol cocked and ready to go.
- [Interviewer] Was it
because he was molesting you?
- No, because he was in there, hurting,
he was in the room hurting my mom.
(Interviewer mumbles)
Right, and he, he wanted her
to do things for her dope.
And all I heard was her crying
and begging and pleading
and by this time I'm like,
I'm like 16, you know.
We were living in, we're
living in Fairfield.
'Cause she was working
at Vacaville prison.
And that's when I started
getting in a lot of trouble.
I've gotten, I got
arrested for shoplifting.
I got arrested for, what is that called,
assault and battery with
a weapon, with the weapon.
I had got expelled from school.
And from there I had got kicked
out of the state of California.
I was, yeah, I got kicked out
of the state of California
for a year.
I could not come back to
California for a whole year.
I was ordered to court.
I was declared a menace
to society and myself.
I went to a group hall on the night that,
a whole bunch of stuff, just, all this-
Everything just went whack.
I mean, I was, I was bad.
I was good at fighting and-
- [Interviewer] You were still a teenager?
- I'm still a teenager.
I did all this between the ages of 15
and I think it was like 17, yeah, 17.
And I was, I was bad.
I was just this close to going to YA.
And that was, when I had-
- [Interviewer] You were supposed to go?
- Gone to YA, CYA.
It's a, it's like a mini prison for kids.
Instead of it to be in juvenile halls,
something bigger, like prison.
And I was, I was real close to going there
and they sent me, my mom-
My mom gave up her
rights, parental rights.
That's when they kicked me out
of the state of California.
And I had to go, I had to move to Arizona
and everything was all right there.
But then I came back and when I came back,
I started drinking.
Once I started drinking,
I started smoking weed.
I smoked some Sherm.
I started smoking, I started taking acid.
I mean, I was doing, I was
doing just way, way too much.
And during all that, I got raped.
And then in the midst of me
getting raped, I got pregnant.
I didn't know I was pregnant.
My body was still normal.
Everything was still the same.
You know, my menstrual,
everything, everything was right.
No sickness on that, and I
didn't find out I was pregnant
till I was like six and
a half, seven months.
Yeah. And I had no stomach.
My stomach was still flat.
I felt no fluttering, none of that.
None of that, none of that stuff.
None of the things that I
should have felt, I never felt.
And when I finally found I was
pregnant, my mom disowned me.
She put me out, we had nowhere to go.
Didn't know what I was going to do.
So at the beginning of my
pregnancy, well the beginning,
I mean the end, it was,
it was, it was sad.
It was really sad.
I was homeless and sleeping outside.
Things like that.
And I don't know what happened, but she,
I guess she had a change of heart.
And one day her and my sister
was out looking for me.
They came and got me
and I was back at home
and I had my daughter.
And once I had my daughter, she took over.
When she took over, I went
right back to the same thing.
Doing the drugs.
This time I was introduced to crack.
And that's when primos,
I started smoking primos.
Woo wee, when I started
smoking primos, oh my god,
that's when I really
got into the drug scene.
That's what it just went haywire.
- [Interviewer] What are primos?
- Primos is tobacco
and smashed down crack.
When you smash your crack
down and you lace it.
You lace the tobacco with
that, you roll it up.
And I was smoking those.
I, it was like I couldn't wait to, like,
get away from my mom.
We were living in Suisun at the time
and I couldn't wait till I turned 18.
The minute I turned 18, I
got a flight outta there
and I moved to Sacramento.
That was probably one of the worst things
I could have ever done in my life.
But once again, that didn't stop me
because out there in Sacramento, I,
I thought I could basically
do whatever I wanted to do.
And then be this big dope
dealer and all this other stuff.
So, I started selling drugs.
I would have, like, the
main supplier, you know,
he would, he would come over
and he showed me how to cook.
I learned to cook dope.
I mean, it was like, it
was like, it was like,
I'm not gonna say I was rich, but it was,
I felt like I was rich.
Cause I, you know, back
then and they, you know,
you get the food stamps
and the food stamps are in paper form.
And I mean, I would have a
drawer full of food stamps
and you know, my mom would
come down once a month
and I would grab them and
give her all the food stamps.
I always had money.
I mean, I was never broke.
I just thought I was, I thought I was,
I'm just gonna be blatant,
I thought I was the shit,
you know.
I really did.
I thought I was the shit.
You know, I get to smoke
my dope when I want to.
I'm here by myself, I got an apartment.
You know, all my bills are paid.
You know, I never, you know,
I had a jar full of money orders.
So whenever I had to pay a
bill, all I had to do was
go ahead and grab the money.
I mean, it was, it was lovely.
But, I ended up
dealing with both sides of the gangs,
of the, you know, of the gangs
and I was dealing with a Blood
and then I met a Crip and I didn't know.
I knew what I did know.
I figured because I
thought I was, you know,
the shit and everything,
that I could, you know,
play around with both of them.
And the guy that, the Crip,
the guy that I had met,
he stayed around the corner
and I got to know him better.
And he started coming
around, coming around more.
Then he already knew, but he
tried to act like he didn't
know that my main supplier,
the guy that I'd worked for
was a Blood.
Long story short, eventually
what happened is that he
set up a robbery for me to get robbed.
And it didn't, I assume
it didn't plan out the way
it was supposed to because
I was in a, what they call,
a cocaine coma.
Which is, you're up for days and then you,
when you go to sleep,
you're dead to the world.
You don't hear nothing.
You don't feel nothing.
You just, you're gone.
And they couldn't get in the house.
I lived in a little apartment
and they couldn't get in.
So, what they did is they shot.
They shot my apartment up.
They riddled it with bullets, I mean.
- [Interviewer] The cops?
- No, no.
The rivals.
- You mean the Bloods?
Yes, the gang-bangers.
They wanted, they were coming to rob me.
But yeah, but I was so asleep,
they knocked, whatever,
they weren't able to get in.
So they took it upon themselves
to shoot up my apartment.
And they, when I say they
shot up my apartment,
they blew out all my windows.
I was told they used the
'45 because they blew the
door off the hinges.
My front door.
Blew it straight off the hinges.
And they didn't even kill me
and they just shot it up
real, real good, oh god.
I mean, and I thought somebody
was knocking at my door.
Yeah. So I jumped up, I jumped up
and as I'm walking to the door,
walking to the door,
I hear these gunshots.
I'm like, oh my god,
dropped to the ground.
I let them do they do.
And like I said, they
blew out all the windows.
The door came off the hinges, I mean,
bullets flying everywhere.
I'm like, looking for cover.
And I'm like, glass is-
'Cause I, the way the apartment
was, is that you come in
and there was a window right
here for the living room.
Then there was a window right there.
But the living room had two windows.
Then it was a kitchen window
and you go around this way.
Then my bedroom window
and my bathroom window.
They went through the whole
thing and shot it all up.
But then the police finally come, now see,
that when the police
finally do come, the bullet,
there was bullets lodged
in the walls and stuff.
And there was one bullet
that went through my wall,
through my closet, through
my closet in my bedroom,
through some clothes, through the wall,
through the neighbor's wall
and it landed like two inches
from the gas heater.
Yeah, that was on the wall.
That right there is what made
me go to smoking the pipe.
That's when I was introduced to the pipe.
I introduced myself to the pipe.
I was like, "Oh, this is
primo is not going to do it."
I got scared.
I didn't want to go home.
And I went to a friend's,
a customer's house,
that was coming to buy drugs from me.
And I told her, they set
me up, give me a pipe,
I want a pipe.
This is not working.
And she did that, and I've been smoking,
I was smoking, I've been smoking
crack since the age of 19
all the way up to early last year.
I can say now I am 11
months clean of crack.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yeah. I don't smoke crack anymore.
But in the meantime, you know,
that transition to smoking crack,
I've been through so, so
much that I never, I never
I would've never thought that
crack had anything to do with
all the issues and problems
that I had, until now.
Now I see that everything
that I went through in my life
is 'cause I was fucking with that crack.
And, and I wanted everything so easy.
You know, I'm not slow, I'm not dumb.
I was straight A student in school,
all the way up through 12th
grade, straight A student.
Like I said, when I started,
when I was introduced
to the primos, that right there,
it was really fucking up
because that's the way that I,
I dropped out of school.
I didn't, I didn't graduate,
but I did get my GED.
That's when I ended up getting pregnant.
All that stuff happened.
But I never, nobody
could tell you that drugs
had anything to do with that.
I just, I was just too smart.
Through that, you know, through all that,
I had a dream after the
little shootout and stuff,
I had a dream of, you
know, I can't do this,
they're going to kill you doing this.
I wanted to be a mule. (laughs)
Which is someone who transports drugs.
I'm like, okay.
Yeah. I can make more money doing that.
You know, I just wanted, I
want wanted everything so,
I wanted everything easy.
I wanted everything to come easy to me.
I didn't want to-
I knew, I mean, I was, I was intelligent.
I was smart.
I could get a job.
I could do whatever, but
I didn't want to do that.
I just wanted my money to come easy.
I wanted to run the streets.
I wanted to be the
party girl, I wanted to,
I'm going to do all that.
And that's initially, initially
how I ended up here in LA
is transporting drugs
and I was transporting marijuana.
And that's after all the shootout
and all that stuff happened.
I was like, I can't be out here anymore.
I was scared.
I didn't want to be
there, down there anymore.
And the guy that I was going
with ended up going to the pen.
And he got out, he got an early release,
I don't know how he got out.
And they took him and they
slaughtered him behind the,
what is that, Sacramento state.
Yeah.
They found him hog-tied.
Hog-tied and executed.
Execution style, shot
in the back of the head.
And my mom working, her being,
her working at the prison,
there was word that, you know,
they were supposed to
come after, you know,
his girlfriend or whatever.
And I was his girlfriend, so I was scared.
So I had to leave.
I had to leave Sacramento.
And that's when I started
doing the transport
and that's my way of leaving.
Got stuck.
How?
'Cause we were riding on the freeway.
Three girls.
Me and two other girls.
And we got pulled over
by the highway patrol.
They found the weed.
I don't know.
I, well I know now, 'cause of
God, but when they stopped us,
none of us went to jail.
We all got cited.
And we were all told that we
could not leave LA County.
We cannot leave LA County
until after we go to court.
So, I was stuck down here
in the middle of doing that.
What I do, I run into
somebody else named Gucci,
that was selling dope.
That was selling crack.
And what I do, I ended
up selling crack again.
Then that's when I was
introduced to being abused.
That's when I was in an abusive,
my first abusive relationship.
I was scared to leave.
So once I got done with
all my court stuff,
you know, my mom was like,
when you coming home,
when you coming home, I'm like,
"Oh, I'll be home. I'll be home."
But I never would come.
And the reason why is because
he told me I can't go.
So I was stuck there.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever done prison time?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Before this or after this?
- This is after, it's after that, I went,
it's so funny, all this I'm telling you-
- [Interviewer] In the
story, up until now-
- Right?
- [Interviewer] Have you been in prison?
- No.
- You've been clean.
- You've been clear.
- I have been clear.
I've never seen a jail
cell a day in my life,
unless, until, once when I was a teenager,
when I went to do juvi hall,
went to the holding, where they hold you
and then your parents got to come get you.
That was the furthest I got.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- But you know, to make
a long story short,
since you said that, I
went through all that.
When I was there, when I
was with the guy, Gucci
I was able to get up out of that
'cause he ended up going to jail
and I made a run back to
Saisun to be with my mom.
But I had to come back again
'cause I had another court date
when I came back, that's
when I met my husband.
And then when I met him,
that's where I stayed.
I ended up staying down here.
Once I (laughs), this is crazy.
I met him at 20.
We were together for a whole 11 years.
From the day that we met,
he took me out to eat.
We met on a Thursday.
We went out to eat on a Friday.
I never left.
Me and him moved in with
him and his grandmother.
And that's when I
experienced Sherm, with him.
I experienced Sherm,
all of that good stuff.
I went to school.
I went to school for administration.
I went, then I went to school for
certified nursing assistant.
Then I was going, then I went to school
for medical assistant
from the back office.
So I did all of that
within that 10, 11 years
plus I had another child, I had a son.
My son and my daughter,
they're seven years apart.
That's the good part.
That life right there that
I'm telling you right now,
there's really nothing
bad that happened here.
Everything through that was like living
in a house with a white picket fence.
I mean, everything was so perfect.
But, what, the 10th year, that's when,
that's when this life
right here that I'm living
right now started.
When is it, the 10th year of
me and him being together.
We were smoking Sherm and
he blames it on the Sherm,
he cheated with my best friend.
I had just had the baby.
And we were gone to my
grandmother's 50th wedding
anniversary with my mom
and my sister and them,
and came back and lo and behold,
who do I find in my bed with
my husband, my best friend.
So that right there, just
the story, my everything.
That's when I gave up.
I gave up, like I said, it's whatever man.
You know, I left him, them, my child.
I just signed away parental
rights and all of that,
all of that good stuff.
Signed away everything and I just,
I don't even think I packed a bag.
I believe I just left.
I left and-
- [Interviewer] You signed
over your parental rights to-
- To my husband, right.
To my husband, for my son.
I gave him-
- [Interviewer] Your second child?
- My second child, yeah.
My child, my kids have two different dads.
I signed over the rights
and I just, I left.
And when I left, I left to the streets.
I didn't go to my mom.
I didn't go to nobody.
I went straight to the
streets and that's when...
That's when I ended up
seeing that good ol'
cell they had for me,
waiting for me in Chowchilla.
So, you know, I left him and from there
all my life was just,
yeah, excuse me if I start crying,
but my life just went downhill.
Five years.
(sniffling)
I been out here five years.
Everything just-
When my mom-
When my mom disowned me,
she wouldn't talk to me no more.
And she wouldn't let me
see my daughter no more.
That's when I got raped, gang raped and
a whole lot of stuff just happened.
I got robbed, left for dead.
So much happened.
That's when I can say,
I wish I had my mom then,
but I didn't, I was just,
I was gone.
I was overwhelmed and taking my drugs.
And that's how I did it.
I mean, I did it day in and day out.
From the time I woke up to
the time I went to sleep.
(sniffling)
Got caught in turning tricks and my body
and stuff like that, you know.
Any opportunity I had, if I
was able to go to my mom's,
then I would steal from her.
I'd steal things from her and sell 'em.
I caused my mom a lot of,
a lot of stress and pain
and she never trusted me again.
(sniffling)
That hurt with everything,
it just, so much happened.
I mean I went through so much to this-
Til the age of 31.
I was 31 when I left my husband.
31 in January.
By the end of the year, I
was, by the end of the year,
by Christmas I had a cell in Chowchilla.
And that was my first time
ever being fingerprinted.
- [Interviewer] Sorry?
- That was my first time ever
been fingerprinted, arrested,
you know, it happened in March.
In March.
I was only in jail for
probably like 32 hours.
Then, after that 32 hours.
That next time I did a trip to a jail cell
was for eight months.
Yeah, like eight months in prison.
While buying drugs.
- [Interviewer] That's for possession?
- Possession.
It was for possession.
No sales case, no nothing else.
It was possession.
I was just so hard-headed
and I was defiant
and I didn't feel I had to, I
feel I can do what I wanna do.
I ain't got to listen.
Fuck the law.
Law can't tell you what to do.
I can do, you know, I
can do what I want to do.
I just, I was, when I
say I was running a muck,
I ran a muck
and I thank God,
now I thank God,
I thank God that I'm still here.
I tried suicide several
times and it didn't work.
And I'm still here.
And when I was five,
they pistol whipped me.
You know.
Thank God, they put the gun
to my head and they clicked it
and it jammed.
So,
thank God it jammed.
- [Interviewer] You're saying
they put the gun to your head?
- Yeah, they put the gun to my head.
- [Interviewer] The gun, I mean, the gang?
- Well, it wasn't a
gang, it was one person.
Cause I was selling him,
like I said, it just,
I just had this thing for selling dope.
And I knew that selling
dope, it would support,
I was gonna be able to support my habit
and I wouldn't have to-
'Cause I felt real nasty when I would do
the turning of the tricks.
And once I had gotten
raped, that's when I,
sex, I never, after that I
didn't have no interest in it
at all.
But I still was me, I still was me.
And I still dressed the same way.
I still act the same way.
But sexual, sexually, I didn't,
I was not interested in sex at all.
I never wanted anybody to-
That's why people are saying I'm mean.
I just, I know I'm mean.
And I can be real, a real bitch.
Just real, just-
But I, you know, I try to be a
better person, a nicer person
but it's really hard because
I don't want that to happen to me no more,
because I don't want to be so,
I don't want to be too nice
and guys get the wrong idea.
That's why you hear music
loud and it's not like that,
it's, I'm drowning
everything out around me.
I don't want to, I don't
want to deal with anything.
I don't want to deal with
the real world out there.
Like I said, I tried, all
these scratches and scars
I got down here, they'll tell you.
- [Interviewer] Suicide attempts?
- Yeah.
Yeah. I've even taken a handful
of pills, that didn't work.
I went to sleep, I woke up.
You know, now, you know,
and there's one person that
that I would be busy
thinking about from day one
and I would and that'd be my daughter.
Cause she's never treated
me any differently.
She's never-
She's always loved me.
She's always letting me in.
She's there for me.
She's there for me like I
should be there for her.
- [Interviewer] When's
the last time you saw her?
- Last week.
She comes to see me every week.
It's crazy, 'cause wow.
I should've been, I should've
been doing some real time.
Really, I should have.
- [Interviewer] But
because your mom was in
Department of Corrections?
- But because of,
I believe because my mom was in
the Department of Corrections and God.
- [Interviewer] That's it.
- I just did that one,
that one time, you know.
- [Interviewer] But now
you're living on the streets?
- Now, you know what, I've
been living on the streets
since I was 31.
- [Interviewer] Now
you're doing crystal meth?
- Now I'm doing crystal meth.
(laughs) Crystal meth.
- What are you doing?
I have a boyfriend.
I have a man.
He's in jail right now.
But nobody has dared to cross the line
to even try to come at me like that.
And because of what I've been through,
I can't see myself going out there
and doing sexual favors for drugs.
- [Interviewer] You've never done that?
- I have.
That's what I'm saying, I have and-
Ugh, ugh, I can't, I can't, I mean,
it doesn't feel good.
It really doesn't feel good.
I feel less than.
Very, very, just, just, ugh.
I mean, that means that
I'm telling myself that
I'm only worth drugs.
Drugs is, that's all I'm worth.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't.
No, I don't.
I just, I can't do it.
I've done it.
And I've said never a
million times in my life
but I can honestly say I
will never, I just can't.
I just, I don't, I don't feel it.
I feel now, I feel ugly.
It feels it's worthless.
- [Interviewer] Thank
you for talking to me.
- No problem, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting story.
- Yeah. I mean, I've been
through, I've been through
some seasons.
I've been through a lot and
I'm still going through a lot.